this episode of congratulations let me
start over
episode 87 of congratulate now this
episode of congratulations is brought to
you by the cash app you know the cash
app it's the simplest way to instantly
send money to friends it's also the
number one app in finance but it didn't
get there on payments alone these days
cash app is changing how people interact
with their money it's adding features
you can only get from a bank and more
than a few that you can like the cash
card boosts and bitcoin download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play mark what's up my babies
it's a baby roll call episode 87 of
congratulations and we just keep on
moving it man we take it a day at a time
in a week at a time and that turns into
months at a time and then years at a
time do you feel what I'm saying
everyone who's saying taking it a day at
a time they're taking the weeks at a
time too they're also taking the years
at a time they're basically just picking
an arbitrary amount of time and saying
it that they're saying it they're taking
it at a time you can see I you could say
you're taking it a minute at a time you
could take you're taking it two minutes
at a time you could say you're taking it
37 seconds at a time but a lot of people
say that they're taking it a day at a
time and that's how they get through the
[ __ ] life and there you go if that's
just makes you a better person than good
we got it [ __ ] we got some we got some
we got some [ __ ] here new at the
congradulations studios it feels like
every week we get a new thing here at
congradulations studios we've got of
course the New Deal the way it looks
we've got the [ __ ] you know the wood
planks here keeping it nice and cozy we
should get a fireplace soon but we're
not going to do that we got the sign
here the congratulations sign we also
have the the CUDA here to keep us a
reminder to give us a reminder of how
not to be right to fight that inner CUDA
but we also have today something that
isn't going to benefit you guys in a
direct way but it is indirect
play okay we've got one of those
soundless noiseless fans now let me tell
you something
it's from Dyson right it's a Dyson
[ __ ] thing yeah okay it's from Dyson
you know the commercials where the guys
just like Dyson we try to make the
things we try to make it from the ground
up we looked at the fan and what we did
is we look at the vacuum and what we
what we did is instead of making the
vacuum like people usually make we
redefine the vacuum and now the vacuum
does what a new thing Dyson I'm a guy
with long gray hair obviously but yeah
so and here's the thing this fan that's
putting out no noise puts out [ __ ]
noise that's the thing when you put it
on high it's literally like I mean you
know what it sounds like a [ __ ] fan
that's it it's got a [ __ ] oval shape
shaped like a [ __ ] big old like big
big giant [ __ ] a little bit you know
you'd have to take into account giant
dicks too so I mean yeah you'd be like
aw but every time you say something
looks like a [ __ ] online people will be
like yeah well what kind of [ __ ] are
you just seeing yeah did we get it here
at Dyson guys I was wandering around
here see the Dyson commercials always
wandering around a [ __ ] laboratory
with like a bunch of [ __ ] crazy
electronic [ __ ] he picks up like a
vacuum that's purple long and purple and
[ __ ] the most the most power here at
Dyson we make it the most powerful
cordless vacuums this way you don't trip
over yourself when you're vacuuming you
can't hair but yeah so we got one of
those one of those fans I let me tell
you something babies it makes noise if
you're trying to get a noises fan well
let me tell you something they don't
exist you don't know is this fan is one
of those Japanese ones where you just
[ __ ] hold and fan yourself like
you're a batterer I have somebody do it
like you're a bad guy get a [ __ ] leaf
anytime airs moving it's gonna be making
noise you know why wind no makes noise
wind so we got one of those fans and
it's got to [ __ ] make me a little bit
cooler hopefully you won't if I'm
wearing like gray shirts if I'm gonna
wear the Grand Slam tea do it do you
know what I mean you won't be able
see my [ __ ] flop sweat you won't be
able to see my sweat you won't be able
to see you know and now granted you
won't be reminded about those [ __ ]
that ski course of the [ __ ] double
black diamonds but still dude they were
there you have to believe in it like
Jesus Christ don't hell for saying that
yeah check but it's all good um so yeah
I took I was in Toronto I did [ __ ] I
was in Ottawa Toronto and also London
Ontario and let me tell you something
somebody told me that they flew to
London by mistake London Europe in
Europe they went to Europe by mistake
they flew they took the thing they took
the flight they went to Europe and they
got there and then they [ __ ] up and
realized that I was gonna be in London
Ontario no I don't know where they were
from originally but they sent me a
message and they literally said that
they were in London and they were like
oh well I guess I'll enjoy it I'll have
to [ __ ] come over to see you at some
other time fly over the pond
I felt real bad but also that's gonna be
a funny story in years and years but
also enjoy London I guess you know but
that's so [ __ ] crazy that that
actually I was also don't you get
tickets maybe she bought the tickets
already but she just bought yeah I think
she said she did she bought the tickets
but she messed up and went to London she
got a flight to [ __ ] London in Europe
hey check have got a I've got a I've got
something for you check check the
itinerary and check website hey don't go
to the wrong place in the world you know
what I mean if you're like yeah I'm
going to tender greens oh ok cool meats
at 10 degrees and you wind up at the one
on Sunset instead the one in unfuckin
Ventura Boulevard fine but imagine go
into the wrong place in the world
Hey Dude sorry
I [ __ ] up I know you're in Canada but
I'm in Europe oh well guess I'll have a
[ __ ] good time anyway god dammit it's
never set up the right way the [ __ ]
soundboard never is sent up the right
way set up the right way and it's not
working there we go
I'll have fun in Europe sometimes they
flag my videos because I play that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] by the way YouTube we
all know that nobody's gonna be
listening to [ __ ] you're making my
dreams come true off on my [ __ ]
congratulations podcast no one's that
doesn't satisfactory for people if they
want to listen to this song Hey Dude but
we don't have to buy it for 140 instead
just turn on congratulations find the
part it syncs up with and even though
crystal T is talking over it let's
listen to it that way give me a [ __ ]
break
um anyway so that's a crazy [ __ ]
thing and I took Air Canada to get to it
let me tell you something mare Canada
get Wi-Fi on your [ __ ] planes man
it's 2018 I know we talked about this
but dude if you're gonna be in 2018 be
in 2018 don't be in 2001 the planes are
new get Wi-Fi on it and I know this is
like a first this is everything this
drives me nuts all first world problems
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] dude there is a
first world we're in it if you're
listening to this you're most likely in
the first world yourself get Wi-Fi I get
on the plane to Air Canada do you guys
have Wi-Fi mmm this airplane doesn't
have it yet
oh cool what airplane we take in this
one then don't say that you smug ass yet
dude don't ever say the word [ __ ] yet
to me on an airplane you know yeah this
aircraft first of all they never call it
an airplane when you work on a plane you
call it an aircraft now that makes me
BRM that's like when actors call it
their craft or whatever when they're
like well you know I'm just honing my
craft you read minds
it didn't even write them you're honing
your craft or he's saying what you
spouse dude honing your craft
yeah dude well you know I like I go to
act I got I got a my my acting class
taught by some guy he
[ __ ] most notably nine episodes of the
second season of jag and anyway he also
was on some of the CSI [ __ ] Miami and
did some CSI New Orleans and he was in a
movie in [ __ ] 2009 with Jay Baruchel
where he played his teacher but still
I'm just honing my craft every week with
that guy oh yeah are you
yeah honing your craft dude no it's good
to practice I'm just [ __ ] around uh
you do after practice that's the other
thing too a lot of people move out here
as actors and they just want to be
[ __ ] actors they just want Fame they
just want to do it like that that's not
cool man
you can't do it like that you got to
practice you do have to hone your craft
actor actually as much as I'm making fun
of it
you got to uh you got a hone your craft
and you also have to [ __ ] practice
everything you do you know like I used
to think about that when I was a
stand-up when I am I mean I immersed in
it but when I was starting like I was
like dude I want to go onstage every
[ __ ] night that's the thing that was
the difference I had a buddy that was
getting work as an actor more than I was
when I first started stand-up and he
loved auditioning I [ __ ] hate
auditioning and he loved auditioning
because he loved it he would practice
auditioning and then go on the audition
they could sniff it out and they could
be like this guy's a professional and
they'd [ __ ] hire him me I wanted to
do stand-up I would go up and do shows
that [ __ ] for five people at some bar
in North Hollywood with the TV's on
because I loved it and and other
comedians who didn't want it as much not
to saying that there weren't some that
did want it as much of course they did
but some of the comedian's that would
would uh would watch would would would
would would want to be a comedian they
wouldn't want it that much and they
wouldn't do those spots and that's how
[ __ ] you get successful um coming out
I don't know well - no but that's what
II yeah that's it I don't know but my
whole [ __ ] point is Air Canada get
Wi-Fi when you're gonna get it oh maybe
October they said are cool well let's
just wait till October to fly then do it
mmm it's not if you're good
have your business goin get your
business [ __ ] going that's my whole
thing man I've talked about this before
on the podcast like if it's gonna work
make it if it's gonna work don't make it
if it doesn't [ __ ] work you know you
know when you go in a [ __ ] office
business office [ __ ] whatever and
they're like how the Wi-Fi is kind of
temperamental then don't have it don't
[ __ ] have it then cuz I can still use
my cellular data to [ __ ] send a text
off but in the air have it 2018 I slept
on the flight it's also so I was reading
a thing too that said like 41% of people
I think Nikki Glaser posted this on
Twitter she was it was the thing about
how 41% of people think it's rude to
recline your seat on the near on an
airplane and 59% of people don't dude
recline go ahead recline if I'm behind
you recline all the way into my [ __ ] go
ahead I'll give you a [ __ ] scalp
massage because guess what I'm doing -
I'm reclining as well into the [ __ ]
housewives you know belly behind me
that's all that's all that's it dude or
everybody recline into our privates go
ahead put your head put the back of your
head in [ __ ] dicks and [ __ ] when
you're on a plane and they give you the
alright yeah and that's a you know
everybody get moving but recline them
sagging that's all you gotta do is bang
a Zygon you ever tried to ER the
airplane and you're not sure if you can
hear it better from their headphones or
you can for you take them off your like
you can I can't hear the [ __ ]
sometimes it's so [ __ ] loud they're
just like they're just like oh we reach
10,000 feet and you're like Jesus Christ
I'm trying to take a nap and sometimes
it's literally like Canada here cares
just taking a vacant Langston feedin no
I kind of didn't looking out inside see
Mount Rushmore see ya
also who's looking out of the [ __ ]
plane at [ __ ] I don't know maybe I would
do that
but I never I feel like I can never see
it like I'm like too high up I'm like is
that it or is that
um yeah but recline into my [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ]
I'll recline into your [ __ ] err [ __ ] if
you're a guy I'll refine into your [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] the back of my
head's meeting your hey nice to meet you
[ __ ] I'm a this is the back of my head
nice to meet you
let's chill for a little bit on our way
to [ __ ] Buffalo and then when we land
nice chatting with you see you later
hopefully you're not a boner hopefully
your flaccid get you later
um I mean Jesus Christ we'll have to
[ __ ] am I talking about here really well
what is important though is which is
crazy to me and not that they didn't
deserve it they deserve it but what's
[ __ ] insane to me what I've been
thinking about lately is the two guys in
jail our [ __ ] Suge Knight and Bill
Cosby Bill Cosby has three to ten years
and Suge Knight has 28 years in prison
dude imagine living first of all Cosby's
what eighty one imagine living 81 years
free and then having to probably spend
the rest of your life in jail I mean
he'll probably get out in three years
who knows if it'll be alive and at that
point I'm sure it's probably hard to
stay alive in prison just with your
health breaking down and [ __ ] and even
your mental health cuz I'd [ __ ] end
it at 81 [ __ ] that dude you got to leave
your wife and you got to be locked the
[ __ ] up and you deserve it and you know
you deserve it Wow and Suge Knight as
bad as he was his whole life has got to
be still in jail for 28 years dude he's
gonna be 81 when he gets out why did she
ignite and Bill Cosby in jail together
Suge Knight and Bill Cosby should not be
like
[ __ ] let's make an album of your
jokes [ __ ] and Bill Cosby like
how stupid is a bill cause anyone who
ever does a Bill Cosby yeah it's like
Christopher Walken now you know if
someone's at a party and they're like
yeah that's Christopher Walken that
guy's the most boring guy at the [ __ ]
party um yeah do it but that's crazy
that they're gonna be in jail dude when
I was a kid I used to listen to [ __ ]
Bill Cosby and all the Suge Knight's
production you know that's so crazy that
those guys if you told the young me that
I was gonna be in jail that they were
gonna be in jail I would be like what
I'd be like maybe Suge Knight but not
Bill Cosby that's [ __ ] insane dude it
blows my mind and yes I know they
deserve it it's weird too cuz it's hard
to separate that [ __ ] for me it really
is like even that we have with xxx
Tenkasi own or whatever like he was a
[ __ ] but his music was great or
whatever it's hard for me to separate it
though you know like the art and what
they did because what Bill Cosby did for
people and and and and the black
community was was insane but then what
he did was rape lots of girls and that's
it's just so [ __ ] it's such a mindfuck
man I don't even like he'd like to the
fact that he can be in because I know
there's people out there that are like
yeah he's in jail he deserves it but I
still feel badly because they know the
[ __ ] they know what the [ __ ] he you
know they they they grew up on God
that's [ __ ] crazy man and his wife is
standing by him still I don't know if
she still is but [ __ ] that's just being
in jail I talked about this before when
would you start [ __ ] guys it would
take me eight days but when would you
end up killing yourself dude if I had to
spend my life in jail I think I'd
actually [ __ ] this is supposed to be
a comedy podcast but I think I'd [ __ ]
I don't think I could do it
I don't think I could [ __ ] do it I'd
go out into some jokey way like my last
[ __ ] line would be like Superman and
then just jump off the [ __ ] thing I
used to think when I was a kid like when
I grow up
I would get [ __ ] way way way old and
I'd go I'd go out onto a bridge with my
oldest buddy and be like hey dude check
this out I'm Superman and just dive off
and then that's how I would die when I
was [ __ ] like 90 and it would just
throw everybody for a loop and I would
know like well you know the best years
are behind me [ __ ] it I went out with a
joke that would be [ __ ] memorable we
all want to be memorable right
it's crazy how [ __ ] bill cos was
gonna be memorized remember remembered
as the guy who [ __ ] you know he's
gonna be remembered as the guy who raped
a bunch of women but I don't think Suge
Knight's gonna be remembered as the guy
who [ __ ] ran that other guy over and
killed him he's gonna be remembered as
the the the CEO at death row that's
weird it's you know you know what it is
to is because Suge Knight was a bad guy
and he made money what I mean is
obviously because he was a bad guy but
he he his image was a bad guy Bill
Cosby's image wasn't a bad guy they
didn't know that that's what he was and
so now he's gonna be known as the
[ __ ] bad guy that's [ __ ] wild huh
that's crazy that history's gonna do
that just because he [ __ ] had that
goody two-shoes if you're yeah
wow it's [ __ ] insane drag the [ __ ]
everywhere I go I try to [ __ ]
actually let's do these first yeah post
mates as usual your stomach and the rest
of your life are at war you need to eat
but you can't stop what you're doing to
deal with it
the only fast things that deliver are
not what you want introducing post mates
the app that adds a delivery option to
your favorite restaurants imagine
anything you want to eat delivered you
don't have to drive Park or even talk on
the phone to order just download the app
and order 24 hours a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring you
what you want within the hour you can
even see where your food is and track
your driver
you forgot eggs and milk no problem
craving an tasty burger check looking
for the perfect bottle of red wine or a
summer beer order up post mates is your
new long-term booty call for food I use
a postman's I actually just used it I
ordered one of my favorite places beef
steak and they picked it up and dropped
it off right before I did this podcast
my baby so for a limited time post mace
is heaven is giving you $100 a free
delivery credit for your first seven
days to start your free deliveries
download the app today and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days save the hassle get the food you
love fast at post mates with code with
code Congrats Mott and bow quality jeans
that look great fit great and feel great
used to cost you hundreds mahtim bow has
permanently changed the game with $200
designer jeans for half the price
introducing mat and baucom where you can
get the most comfortable premium jeans
you will ever wear for half of what
you'd pay elsewhere for a G or seven
jeans these are luxury jeans for a
hundred bucks and you can only get them
at Ma and Baucom the most comfortable
the reason why is because they use the
best in comfort technology like dynamic
stretch and that stretch is actually
awesome and you could do high kicks in
them I love doing high kicks in my jeans
premium because they only source their
denim from two of the most
well-respected denim mills in the world
and to make your jeans fit you perfectly
they have an at-home Tryon program
request a second pair with your order
try on both keep one and send back the
other one in the same box with the
prepaid label they also gave me a couple
shirts which are great to that I've worn
these are $200 designer jeans for half
price plus their September savings event
means you will save 20% on everything at
Mont and Baucom slash Congrats that's mo
TT and bo w comm / congrats for 20% off
everything this is there
best deal anywhere but it is only for
the month of September so get on that
save 20% during MOT and bow September
savings event and bow calm / Congrats
get on it my babies
due to a nas in Toronto this company hit
me up collar clothing which is great and
they they were like hey we got we're
based in Toronto they sent me a bunch of
stuff already and they were like hey
we're in Toronto let me send you some
stuff let's send you some stuff and so
I've met him in the lobby they give me
bags of these clothes and I wear them on
stage a lot caller Kol lar but another
thing is remember the story I told when
I went on the hike and I had to use the
a SRV clothing to wipe my my my backside
because I had an emergency up there on
that hike well guess what they did is a
joke they sent me [ __ ] toilet paper
and the knife and three pair of cargo
pants because of what Will Sasso told me
he always brings a knife in case he does
run into a problem hiking he can cut off
the cargo pocket and then use that to
wipe his [ __ ] backside and that's
what a SRV sent to me with no
explanation but I got it I got it
because it was like [ __ ] the Riddler
doing something Batman and they were the
Riddler and they sent me a riddle and I
[ __ ] got it like I'm Batman I got it
and I started B basically he's telling
me on my Batman and I cuz I got it so
thank you a SRV for having a sense of
humor and also sending me really cool
[ __ ] workout clothing which is which
is top-notch dude I [ __ ] I need to
drink that [ __ ] cat poop coffee is
what I can get you drink have you ever
heard of this cat poop coffee oh yeah
well it's something dude one fire
doesn't know what cat poop coffee is
well let's look it up dude what is cat
poop coffee also known as Kopi Luwak of
course is not actually called cat poop
coffee but Kopi Luwak or cat poo coffee
is widely known as the rarest most
expensive coffee in the world retail
prices have reached it reaches as high
as $80 a cup Wow
it's also the world's rarest coffee bean
- this is at cat poop coffee inc.com hey
you know of all websites cat
Coffee ink.com ayats incorporated coffee
berry a cat poop coffee
Kopi Luwak are the coffee berries that
have once been eaten and excreted by a
cat called the Asian Palm Civet civet
Givet so basically a cat called the
Asian Palm Civet eats the berries from a
coffee tree then basically poops them
out I like any article that says
basically by the way that means I'm
gonna be able to understand it from here
a farmer or coffee harvester would grab
the defecated beans and begin processing
them I mean that that what that means is
he's digging through the cat the [ __ ]
cat [ __ ] when the cats kibitz eat the
coffee berries fermentation of the
coffee beans occurs in the cat's
digestive system during this process the
cats the cat [ __ ] you know it seeps into
the EM enzymes seep into the coffee
beans
yeah yada yada unique flavor and aroma
it and [ __ ] so during this entire system
for the beans our trainer imagine going
to a place also
how about [ __ ] how long does that
take
hey one cup of cat [ __ ] coffee please
cool hang around we're clear now it came
out in four hours we gotta wait till
this cat eats these [ __ ] berries
imagine being like yeah one cup of
coffee I'd be like sure and then they'd
feed of [ __ ] berries to the cat and
that you would you like a double shot
yeah cool eat more berries kitty and
then four hours your orders coming up
and then buy and then your [ __ ]
fallen asleep Carl yeah your coffee's
ready
here you go that'll be $80 hey are you
[ __ ] kidding me no cool here's my $80
let me drink it sip oh is it good yeah
how good could it [ __ ] possibly be
what is it [ __ ] press your prostate
dude it's just I mean you're drinking
coffee too [ __ ] most people I think
drink coffee
[ __ ] stay awake anyway you know it's
not look at this 2 Chainz drink 600 all
her coffee made from cat poop most
expensive [ __ ] G kill seems like
something to change would be like he
would drink it and just be like true ty
have some cat [ __ ] coffee cool
here you go two chains let me drink it
true what how good could it be I need to
try that [ __ ] somebody send me some or
just either send me some a cat [ __ ]
coffee or just send me a [ __ ] cat and
those berries and I'll make him myself
what if that's what what if you heard
that was the thing at home you like no I
make my own you open up the cover
there's a cat and a [ __ ] bowl of
cherries I got to wake up at 2:00 a.m.
because I have [ __ ] like my coffee at
6:00 coffee's ready how about that shirt
2 Chainz where's that [ __ ] says CEO
with all the zeros after it
CEO Mia Nair I guess is just trying to
say CEO and heir I mean forking out the
money to pay for the cat food 600 sets
$600 for 2 Chainz here you go
you guys have an ATM cool I have to wait
you know what let me order the coffee at
[ __ ] 10:00 p.m.
because I can't I can only draw with I
can only withdraw three thousand dollars
every day
so then after midnight I'll withdraw
$3,300 again three hundred ollars and
then three hundred dollars after
midnight and then here's your six
hundred dollars true hey bad what is
this world that's somebody how did he
even [ __ ] come about the drink cat
[ __ ] coffee
how [ __ ] bored do you have to be how
[ __ ] hoity-toity rich ass
[ __ ] do you have to be to be
like why don't we try and catch in why
don't we trying to see I've also so rich
on drugs
[ __ ] legitimately on mushrooms which
by the way why eat mushrooms anyway to
be that's how rich they were they
already ate the mushrooms and they're on
mushrooms just like hey why don't we
feed these cherries to cats and then see
if we can make coffee out of the [ __ ] we
can probably charge upwards of $600 for
this
hey hey catch it then there would be
anywhere near my mouth you know where
catch it should be near cats buttholes
and that's it if there's something out
there someone's eating it you know I
[ __ ] when I was a kid I used to I
watch this thing that was like Guinness
Book of World Records this guy was
eating shopping carts hey man he was you
saw that dude he was eating shopping
carts he would like gnaw on it until it
would [ __ ] break free and then he
would eat the shopping part shopping
carts and then I guess hit it out he
probably never made coffee out of that
see that's the thing that guy was
missing a [ __ ] an extra step later
where he should be like oh I can make
money off this [ __ ] shopping cart
Souffle or whatever the [ __ ]
shopping for Souffle um I don't [ __ ]
know bro I I I love coffee so much I
guess if I guess I would drink that
[ __ ] cat [ __ ] coffee I would would
you want fire if you were yeah you would
would you
Ivan get rid of yeah I would too I think
someone who's like like after you
[ __ ] make it hot and [ __ ] I I'm all
good you know all that [ __ ] burns out
and not like I would eat you know I
wouldn't eat cat [ __ ] but when they
ferment it and then [ __ ] clean it and
then [ __ ] make it all boil it or
whatever you know not boil it but get it
real hot like the coffee is can I get I
can I get an iced cat [ __ ] coffee please
can you make it a latte for me I wonder
if they can do that probably not right
how about somebody who's like oh yeah
I'll get the [ __ ] cat [ __ ] coffee I'm
gonna latte but I want it to be with
[ __ ] almond milk be like yeah you're
eating cat [ __ ] you're not gonna drink
what [ __ ] regular milk
I don't know that's kind of [ __ ]
event it's kind of a how to keep premise
Robin Hood is in is an investing app
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and kryptos all commission-free
you like to do this and you don't want
to pay Commission Robin Hood is where
it's at
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just the wealthy
non-intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence check Robin Hood
don't be insecure with this did they do
it all for you other brokerages charge
up to $10 for every trade but Robin Hood
doesn't charge Commission fees trade
stocks and keep all of your profits
gender Stan me easy to understand charts
and market data place a trade in just
four taps on your smartphone you got a
smartphone tap it four times easy to
understand charts and market data do you
understand that because it's hard to
understand but they make it easier Robin
Hood web platform also lets you view
stock collections 100 most popular
sectors like entertainment and social
media and curated categories like female
CEOs and analyst ratings of buy hold
sell for every stock it's so easy that
even I kinda had fun poking around and
making some purchases so that's me and
you know mmm really dumb so I figured I
had to do it Robin Hood is giving
listeners a free stock like Apple Ford
or sprint to help build your portfolio
sign up at congrats dot Robin Hood com
that's Congrats dot Robin Hood com hey
babies the cash app you know the cash
app it's the simplest way to instantly
send money to friends it's also the
number one app in Finance the cash card
is a free customizable debit card that
you can use at stores or ATMs it's
linked to your cash app balance as if it
were a checking account it even lets you
direct
deposit your paycheck if you're looking
for an alternative to traditional
banking you're not alone millions of
America Americans have already started
using the cash card there has never been
a rewards program like boosts get
instant discounts every single time you
swipe a cash card at coffee shops
Chipotle Shake Shack and beyond just tap
a boost in the app and pay with your
cash card cash app is also the most
convenient and inexpensive way to buy
sell and withdraw pyth bitcoin 20 years
ago something like the cash app would
have been really hard to imagine and now
it's hard to imagine anything else and
of course when you download the cash app
and enter rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market it's
my favorite cash at my babies dewd I was
reading this thing the other day too
about it was that [ __ ] thing we were
talking about okay let me just read this
for you I don't know what this is from
what website this is from but it's
called the triple to lack okay I'm gonna
read this for it to you here cuz this I
thought was this summed up how [ __ ]
stupid any religion is okay now look
religion if it makes you a better person
if it makes you happier if it makes your
family happier and closer and you like
own a church I am all for it I am NOT
talking [ __ ] about people who use
religion to make themselves happier
great now am i talking [ __ ] about
religion you bet
do I think it's silly oh yeah
is it hey it's absolutely hey okay
something known as triple to lack now
this is from a website inst it's instant
divorce it allows Muslim men to
immediately terminate a marriage just by
repeating the word 2 lakh which means
divorce in Arabic three times to their
wives
the words can be uttered either in
person or online and the women and the
woman has no recourse like if he writes
talaq talaq talaq online to you you
can't be like no aunt italic there's no
telecoil I have five seconds to do two
like reversal sweetheart don't bother me
on five seconds addicted to thought to
do the two lakh reversal some Muslim
women say they have even been divorced
via whatsapp imagine you got divorced
hey yeah I got divorced really oh that's
tough yeah kind of took this thing out
of it though because it was over
whatsapp and somebody just wrote a lack
three times
hey imagine no explanation just you get
the text so who is this - like - like -
like I'll [ __ ] I'm divorce instantly
tweet it or in letters according to AFP
they've done it in letters like longhand
India's Supreme Court ruled again in
August 2017 that triple till act let
like it's a [ __ ] wrestling move by
the way [ __ ] with the triple to lack
oh and pile drives I'm instead oh here
he goes on the rubs for his signature
the Muslim Menace on the ropes
oh the beginnings of a triple to lack oh
he divorces foot the bone he the boy he
divorced his [ __ ] spine from his head
in India Supreme Court ruled in August
2017 that triple toe Lac was
unconstitutional
hey this [ __ ] hey figure that out in
1912 but legislation how about how
legislation is even mentioned in this
article about divorcing somebody by
saying a word three times like it's a
beetlejuice
legislation passed in December was
stifled by political opposition that
impasse prompted the government of Prime
Minister Narendra Modi to issue the
executive order so it's not you can't do
it anymore I guess wait hold on what
does that mean
they can do it or they can't do it now
so August 2017 the Supreme Court ruled
that triple toe Lac was unconstitutional
but legislation passed in December was
stifled by political opposition oh so
they can do it still I can't tell the
way it's written I'm an idiot maybe you
guys know either way they did it in 2017
but dude imagine being like imagine the
last straw like imagine you're just in a
loveless marriage
how [ __ ] amazing must some of the
Muslims feel when that [ __ ] started
look so look Mohamed said that you know
look we haven't been seeing eye-to-eye
now for six seven years I know our love
has changed
I felt disconnected from you Mohamed
said this guy Mohamed said that I follow
we can get divorced without all of the
paperwork and I just have to tell you
talaq talaq talaq hey huh imagine the
wife here and that for the first time
what let me google it let me google this
hold on one second let me turn on my
phone all right so open on Twitter
anyway did you tweet me to like to like
to like to imagine be like you [ __ ] up
the laundry again to like to like the
lack dude
to lack don't make me [ __ ] don't make
me do the triple look I'm just saying if
you [ __ ] do that again you're getting
the triple two lakh that's all that's
all I'm calling the Muslim Menace dude
I'm getting I'm pulling the triple two
lakh on you two lakh
dude when I [ __ ] read that I laughed
so hard I was crying they deemed it
unconstitutional yeah can't well you
know we're not gonna be able to do that
tell a collector lack the imagine that
Indian men that are just like [ __ ]
hallelujah because they [ __ ] didn't
want to be divorced and they were so
[ __ ] upset that they were even
married in the first place and now
they're just pulling the triple to lack
out of their [ __ ] ass dude on real I
want to get married just to do the
triple to lack and then have my [ __ ]
American girl just be like mm-hmm
are you [ __ ] out of your mind what
happens by the way if she disagree it
says no I'm not going anywhere
I guess you can call the police and you
can be like hey the police came just I
told her did you
hello Indian police yeah what did she's
she's a wife she can stay in the house
yeah no but I told her to like collect a
lock can you prove it while just tell
her again right now hey baby to like
tell like to lack there I want her
removed from my house I make all the
money get her at she's an intruder now
we're divorced instantly take her I mean
Jesus Christ you know this [ __ ] world
dude you got [ __ ] Suge Knight in jail
and every Indian guys are [ __ ] too
lacking all day long wow this fan works
bro if [ __ ] works I wouldn't say I'm
cold but I don't have any sweat going on
[ __ ] yeah man life's about [ __ ]
moving forward my babies I had a bad
week I had a bad week I wasn't happy
this week I was I was a sad I had a sad
week but it's about going on you know
and I was like I don't even know why I
did the podcast today cuz I didn't know
I didn't air could do it yesterday cuz I
was in a [ __ ] foul mood for a week
and today you know I woke up didn't feel
so good still but I knew the babies were
out there listening and
I want to thank you guys for being with
me man because I wasn't happy this week
and I didn't know how I was gonna do
this and I did I did my shows I got
through Toronto shows I got through all
those shows and I [ __ ] did it because
I'm a professional dude you got to do it
did I feel good in my heart when I was
doing it not really but the audience
still you know was happy that I came out
and thank you for that it's [ __ ] tough
man performing when you're like not in a
good space like I'm not like right now
like trying to do this podcast when I'm
just like when I have when there's some
weight on my shoulders
it's [ __ ] hard it's really hard and
it's hard you know and you know this
isn't I know this is a comedy podcast
but it's also a comma it's also every
week and it's also me you know it's a
version of me but it's also me sometimes
and it's hard to shake that weight off
sometimes and just go and do comedy for
you guys especially when I don't know
what I'm gonna say if I know what I'm
gonna say if I'm up there I might do my
my stand-up and all the [ __ ] and I'm out
there doing the thing I know how to make
it funny because I've been doing it but
when I'm here and I don't know what I'm
gonna say to get that feeling of
happiness because you kind of need that
at least for me to do a joke
you know and I can trick myself into
that a lot of the time on a performant
cuz I already know what I'm gonna say
most of the time or I can get into this
loosey goosey type of mode where I'm
just like a [ __ ] what matters in life
anyway Here I am [ __ ] onstage
bullshitting and you guys are here thank
you for coming that kind of whole vibe I
can get into a silly space but I don't
have the audience with me right now I've
got white one fire and Ivan gets rid of
I've got some weight on my shoulders and
I'm still doing this here for you babies
and we got this log cabin right that I'm
knocking on and I'm trying you know I
guess I'm just
for [ __ ] listening really because
I've been thinking lately too like I
never thought about like I've been
watching Will Smith and [ __ ] on
Instagram and just how how great his
family is you know and I know Jayden a
bit and you know i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i
I met will once twice and [ __ ] Jada
once but like I don't know them but you
know I worked with with Jayden
they're just great they're great people
and I was thinking about Will Smith and
like how you can look up to him you know
you really could look up to Will Smith
you can look up to guys like the rock
you can look up to [ __ ] Mark Wahlberg
you know what I mean
he's the family man and he's waking up
when he needs to and I was thinking
about me how about I'm just this mother
[ __ ] who talks [ __ ] on a podcast
and I do stand-up and I talk about
[ __ ] dick jokes and [ __ ] and I did
this in ER in conversation thing at in
conversations thing at a what do you
call it just for laughs and I don't know
how this is gonna sound but I was gonna
tell you guys I I was out there and this
guy was talking to me about you know
stand up and about me and about my
comedy and all that and the the it was
packed you know there were like 200
people there and the guy in the front
row they opened it up to questions guy
the front row he's like hey I just want
you to know he said I don't really have
a question I just wanted to let you I
just want to ask if you knew I guess it
was a question he says do you know that
like I like your comedy like I saw David
Brent but like your comedy [ __ ] has
helped me get out of depression and [ __ ]
and I've had like dark times and it
really m'p and your podcast has pulled
me out of it and helped me out of that
and I wanted to thank you and I was
wondering if you knew that you that it
happens now that's [ __ ] I'm not
trying to obviously I know how it sounds
but my point is is that I didn't I I
actually as stupid as this [ __ ]
sounds like I don't
that because you know I've been
depressed before and I've had problems
like I you know but I don't think about
comedy really as an escape I think about
it as my my my life you know
I don't turn on a comedy when I want to
[ __ ] escape I don't want to escape my
life is generally good and I'm not
usually depressed but he said that and
[Music]
between that and the weight that I've
had this past week it
it made me it made me cry and I'm and
I'm crying right now a little bit but
I'm trying not to but it made me cry a
little bit on stage because it just made
me feel really [ __ ] good and I wanted
to thank that guy on the podcast too for
telling me that because I didn't think
about that that way I didn't think about
it that way and and it it they made me
happy you know and I never thought about
it truly in that way cuz I just come
onstage or I [ __ ] do this podcast and
I just [ __ ] around you know and it's
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] you know it's fun I
do it I I say this before and and and I
stand by it I don't do comedy to make
you laugh I do it to make me not cry and
and I guess it was ironic that it did
make me cry in that moment and it's
making me cry now on this [ __ ]
goddamn comedy podcast and that really
[ __ ] made me think man the rest of
the weekend because of the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that I'm going through and because of
what he went through and how what I did
pulled him out of that
and I started thinking about guys like
Will Smith in the rock and how there are
role models and he'll I I feel like I'm
entering this new phase in my life or or
I'm an adult you know I'm not 40 or
anything and I always imagined myself as
a kid you know cuz you're never as old
as you feel
I mean you're never as old as you you're
not as old as you you resulted you feel
I guess right and my dad said he still
feels [ __ ] young in his head he looks
in the mirror and he sees [ __ ] Dracula
or whatever the [ __ ] with grey hair
however old he is seventy it looks in
the mirror and he's like that's that old
version of me that I never thought I'd
be but I I do feel like I'm entering a
new phase in my life and I want to be a
[ __ ] I want to be one of those guys
or I look up to those guys and I don't
want to be one of these [ __ ] you know
I want to be I guess that guy what I'm
sure I don't even know what I'm trying
to say I want to be a [ __ ] somebody
that I guess people don't just I guess I
want to help the world is what I'm
saying not just in the comedy way and I
didn't think about that
I didn't really think about that until
uh I did this past weekend anyway
[ __ ] man should we do some Twitter
questions or what here we go this is a
good question
Ben Wilkins at Benny buckets jr. who's
your all-time favorite Batman Joker
I like that okay so here's the deal I
think Christian Bale is a great Batman
but I also think that Michael Keaton was
a [ __ ] Michael Caine was like when
you're doing casting there's always that
the casting will do this a lot in
production and they'll have they'll have
the the the one choice that is the
funnier choice the one choice that is
the
look you know and then they'll have the
guy who's like the wild card they call
it a lot or the interesting choice and
you know for instance George Clooney is
just the choice for Batman obviously or
Jon Hamm would be Batman you get it
Christian Bale more you know he's also
he's also kind of that choice cuz he's
you can picture him as Batman Michael
Keaton you don't he's though he was
definitely the wild card and Tim Burton
had clout and has clout and can do that
so he picked Michael Keaton and it ended
up being really [ __ ] cool and
interesting and I think it worked so in
a way in that way because of that and
because Hollywood is always a lot of
more of the same I think maybe Michael
Keaton was my favorite but if I'm gonna
say best I would maybe maybe say maybe
say Christian Bale Joker uh I would have
to go with Jack Nicholson just because
of how [ __ ] he looks like the Joker to
me you know and is and just his whole
vibe is Joker II with his [ __ ]
eyebrows and all that [ __ ] but I'm
[ __ ] really excited to see I I think
Joaquin Phoenix is borderline the wild
card choice of the Joker especially the
way they have them do it it's just have
the pictures that we've seen of them and
all that it makes it look like it's
really interesting and kind of it's got
a sadness to it see that's the thing
that none of the Joker's yet have had a
sense of sadness to him and I don't
think that you need that in a comic book
or if you're going to do the Batman that
Val Kilmer did right that's just a comic
book version of it
but you know the one that Heath Ledger
played was great it just you know and I
don't want to be one of those guys that
like oh yeah [ __ ] because it's real
it's good because it's real like I don't
[ __ ] agree with that movies works
like oh yeah try to make it there's this
whole [ __ ] thing going on now where
it's like oh the realer the more real it
is the better it's like I don't [ __ ]
agree with that some movies are great
and they're not real look at [ __ ]
Fellini and Stanley Kubrick and
David Lynch you know none of that [ __ ]
looks real or seems real at all and
they're great movies you don't have to
[ __ ] actor look at Steve Buscemi in
half this [ __ ] he does he's not acting
like you really like someone really does
but he's [ __ ] great because you saw
the death of Stalin he's [ __ ] funny
and great in that but he's not acting
like how a guy would really act he's
just being a [ __ ] he's doing the part
that is called for in the tone of the
movie and although I think that Heath
Ledger and also what's his name Jared
Leto have done did that totally for the
movie I just don't think that they you
know if you're although this is the
Joker movie so you do want to see more
of his rounded character in this movie
so maybe that's why it does seem like
it's like that I can't fault the other
guys there I mean there I like all the
Batman movies I really do i watch every
Batman movie and I find all of them
entertaining or good or great next one
Alex lamb okay yeah he asked me about
this I saw this when you put your stance
socks on do you have the icon on the
outside or inside of your ankle I uh
this one's like on the inside
aren't they see I could confuse some of
them are in different places some of
them are only on the right side of the
pair some of them are on the inside some
were and you could also put them on the
outside of you put them on different
socks I put them on the outside if
they're if you have the choice but I
have pairs that are only on the on the
right side and I don't know if that was
a [ __ ] up or not but anyway yeah I'd put
them on the outside so you can [ __ ]
get the peak so you can [ __ ] peek you
like to peek right
I love looking at ankles Chris D'Elia
Corey McGill at Corey McGill underscore
Chris Lee a time for ATT to step it the
[ __ ] up yeah I don't like this kind of
[ __ ] cute advertising eighty more for
more for your thing that's our thing ah
what that's so vague and dumb [ __ ] like
that makes me want to go over Eisen more
for your thing that's our thing oh yeah
okay
what they what the by the way seriously
what the [ __ ] are they talking about
more for your thing like bet more bang
for your buck is that what they're
saying I I genuinely I genuinely don't
know I wonder if that's a campaign that
they're starting and we just don't get
it yet you know
yeah dude 18 t get it to [ __ ] and gather
dude more for your thing that's our
thing okay
say oh this is a good question you know
I'm a shoe guy Randall Khan try out
country out at say underscore portugee
at in a [ __ ] you're from [ __ ]
Portuguese Portuguese Portuguese
Portugal what do you think of the new
Jordan 33s congratulations but okay I
will say this about the a so I'm a big
shoe guy always know when the [ __ ]
new shoes come out and all that [ __ ] and
I love them I got my Pumas on right now
the Thunderer I forget what the called
thunder or something Thunder [ __ ]
something anyway
here I'll show them to you from the
video podcast there you go my babies
look at that I got the [ __ ] nice
colors and [ __ ] you're on with the tight
jeans you [ __ ] show your [ __ ]
change so tight that your [ __ ] ball
just popping out dude it's pretty cool I
just said I want to be a role model now
I'm talking about the [ __ ] bulge in
my tight jeans anyway what do you think
of the new Jordan 33 is okay yeah I
think the past [ __ ] 20 Jordans have
been and let me not [ __ ] mince words
here oh god okay ever since like there
are some I think there are like one or
two pairs of 14s that I would maybe wear
I don't like the 13s 12s are fine 11s
are cool tens are good 9s are all right
eight I like don't even have any but I
like they're just so weird
7s six is sure I like them yes they're
they're different and cool
fives tongue is sometimes too big for s
threes or great twos and they're fun
they're cool ones are the all-time best
shoe so
but above 14 I mean they got [ __ ]
it's like Ray Charles made these [ __ ]
shoes without his hands hey now that's
now that's a [ __ ] 12 Michael Jordan I
don't know if you know that but you owe
me 1295 for that grand slam hey Michael
Jordan who signed off on these shoes Ray
Charles with no hands now welcome how
many in your party I've got an open
booth for you oh [ __ ] 38 so the new
Jordan's the new Jordan's are coming
around I would maybe wear them once or
twice they look cool they're trying to
do a little bit of a different thing the
32 is 31 and 30s they were all kind of
like fine not met not very memorable
these are just my reviews what the [ __ ]
do I know about shoes but you asked so
the 33s are all right I think that they
could be coming around on to something
you know that's what's up any other
questions or is that it well that here
we were oh yeah they tell me about a con
a con is 511 even though I said he's 42
well music I grew maybe Hugh finally
went through puberty what the [ __ ] now
he's just like Konvict Muzik just so
[ __ ] oh yeah but kids sell albums why
because he sounds like that [ __ ] sad
clown that that sad clown that sings was
that guy what a wicked thing to he's
saying that [ __ ] I have it here hold on
I have it on my not not Chris Isaak I
mean I know that's a Chris Isaak song
but this [ __ ] thing right here
cool not coming up here we go here it is
here it is puddles pity party right you
ever heard of that this is the new pond
this is Clark this is a con
come with music and then go security
[Music]
save me
this guy's such a good voice though by
the way
[Music]
it's emotional
you can really sit in the tub and slit
your wrists of this song and just feel
okay about it
Oh
you know when that you know they're
gangster when they hit that that's when
they [ __ ] that's that's why you sing
that song doodle-do sound [ __ ]
millions of copies would you love to try
on some large James
convict jeans you know convict jeans you
know who's gonna be wearing some convict
jeans Suge Knight and Bill Cosby
[Music]
all right guys I'm gonna be in be in
[ __ ] Buffalo Vermont and Philly my
babies you coming out we got two shows
in Philly and that's how we're gonna
[ __ ] back up the Brinks truck show
after show we got money we're piling it
in to making this [ __ ] studio an
actual log cabin I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
goddamn bearskin rug and a goddamn
fireplace before you [ __ ] know it
and a beautiful bed and I'm just gonna
live here thank you
my
is for listening Murch is running low we
know that and we'll be getting new stuff
soon I promise
it may even be tomorrow one fire told me
it might be tomorrow but he didn't
confirm it therefore on fire it could be
the next day we don't know go to chris
d'elia calm krisily calm for
follow-the-leader tickets see my news
tour subscribe to the youtube channel
subscribe rate review the show tweeting
it by using the handle congrats part
congrats pod or by using the hashtag
congratulations pod video two videos
episodes go up Tuesdays or Wednesdays
it'll be wednesday at this point watch
my specials and thanks man
I know I got a little emotional dishes
podcast it's kind of one of my fears and
it's gonna happen eventually but it did
anyway thanks for listening I really
appreciate it
[Music]